welcome to bit by bit a series where we
highlight one thing you can do to
optimize and run a bit better in Google
Cloud knowing how to tune workload
requests in gke can be a challenge
getting information to help across
dozens of workloads running across your
Fleet of clusters potentially spread
across different projects even harder
lucky for us gke gives us a starting
point by providing workload
recommendations as metrics out of the
box from vertical pod Auto scaler so
today's topic aggregating these
recommendations from vpa in bigquery and
building a dashboard to help you
navigate your workload right sizing
exercises at scale let's Dive In
[Music]
so workload right sizing exercise in
kubernetes is basically trying to get
workload requests to more closely
reflect actual usage right so for way
over the usage it could be a cost risk
to the business if we're way under usage
with requests it could be performance
reliability risk so this recommendation
service for example is actually using
twice that not the requested CPU and
brushing up against its limits that
recommendation service is just one
workload in one cluster right and the
key to today's discussion is actually
trying to figure out how to do workload
right sizing at scale right where are
the opportunities to actually do
workload right sizing so we don't want
to look at just a single cluster we want
to look across a whole Fleet of clusters
and here you can see I have both
autopilot and standard clusters but we
also want to figure out a way that this
could scale across multiple Google Cloud
projects our Solutions team has actually
published the guide that we'll be
demonstrating today so if you'd like to
follow along check out the solution
guide and its public repository Linked
In the description below
with that said let's actually dive into
what gke provides to the workload right
sizing exercise and so if we look at
recommendation service specific
deployments in one of our gke clusters
we go down to action scale and edit
resource requests what we can actually
see is that gke's console will surface
vertical pod Auto scalar recommendations
for requests for CPU and memory and GK
makes this possible all without us ever
needing to create a vertical pod Auto
scaling object which is nice and this is
great for individual workload owners to
begin to right size but again the core
question that we're trying to solve here
today is how do Platform admins
understand and consume and digest this
type of information at scale with so
many clusters and a fleet it'd be good
for them to understand what workload
teams they might need to work with that
might be at risk for having workloads
under or over provision
now to get to this end state where
platform admins can answer this question
it helps to start with where all of this
information is aggregated and that
brings us to Cloud monitoring because as
you can see here these values for CPU
and memory request recommendations
live not only in the GK console but in
Cloud monitoring as metrics and as you
can see here I'm using metrics Explorer
to just show that we can do things like
group by container name the controller
as well as the CPU request
recommendation value
and now that we know we have access to
these raw metrics in Cloud monitoring
what our solution does next is actually
deploys code as a cloud run job and this
is to export the metrics into a bigquery
data set where we can analyze the
recommendation data and actually make it
actionable for platform admins you can
see we have a cloud scheduler job that
will run this code on a daily basis
and now we can see our bigquery data set
and one important thing to call out is
that because workload usage can change
over time this data set actually
Aggregates recommendation data over a
30-day period
now because it's bigquery of course you
can write your own SQL queries of course
you can create your own dashboard but to
help you make use of this data as
quickly as possible our solution team
has built out a looker Studio template
which you can use to directly connect to
your bigquery tables that you've created
in this data set
and once you create that dashboard
the first thing you'll be greeted with
is this kind of top level view one of
the things to call out is that because
this dashboard is your single pane of
glass so to speak across your Fleet of
clusters and it's based on a bigquery
data set all you'll need to do to
support multiple projects is repeat the
same process as far as exporting metrics
from each project into this centralized
bigquery data set
and once you have all of the metrics
exported into this bigquery data set you
can use the top bar filters to filter
down by region where your clusters are
by the project ID by cluster name or
even by the object type group
and at long last we have the information
that platform admins can use to take
action right we get the meta view where
we can see the total number of
containers analyzed across our Fleet we
get the potential CPU or memory savings
that can come from workload right sizing
and we even get a couple of tables with
our most over provision workloads or our
most under provisioned workloads and we
even get a priority score that can help
us sort of make decisions as far as
which ones are worth tackling or which
ones we want to tackle first as a
platform admin
and finally we have Insight Fleet wide
into workloads that fall into the best
effort or bursible quality of service
classes and the reason that we care
about this is that you know this is
where workloads could fall into a
reliability performance risk they're at
risk to be throttle that is CPU level or
in from a memory perspective they could
be out of memory killed or evicted in in
the case of memory pressure on a
specific node so we want to get a sense
of what our hygiene is Fleet wide
especially if we know that our Fleet is
mostly running critical workloads
and if we wanted a more granular view
um on the details of these
recommendations we can go to The Details
page in this dashboard template and we
can actually filter uh to see these
specific workloads that fall under for
example a quality service class of best
effort
and finally we have the history page on
the dashboard which is a summary level
view of our progress over time when
right sizing workloads for both CPU and
memory basically gives us that view of
recommendations compared to actual
requests is there a lot of opportunity
left on the table to continue workload
right sizing and this serves as a
healthy reminder that is a continuous
Journey between platform admins and
workload owners to right size these
workloads right so it's not a one-time
exercise and this history view gives us
that summary of how we're doing over
time
workload right sizing in kubernetes is a
continuous Journey that your
organization takes on and surfacing the
right recommendations from gke while
prioritizing the actions you can take
only makes you more effective at the
task as always you can learn more at the
links in the description below and we'll
see you in a bit
[Music]